not like the taj mahal they got up there
today
don't even get me started on the food
might as well have been eaten cardboard
yeah it was the pioneer days frontier
the wild west
we were the settlers and the russians
well they were the indians
you gotta give it to gordo he's got
something going on there he's got a
stage presence if you will
hey guys pete here this will be my for
all mankind
season two episode two breakdown so that
you've been warned it will contain
spoilers
if you haven't watched the episode yet
and with that out of the way we can get
right to it
episode 2 is a character based setup
episode
and surprisingly that's not a bad thing
turns out i actually care what happens
to these characters
and the episode opens with molly
concealing the truth about
being exposed to radiation during the
solar storm she tells the crew that she
waited 2 hours and 45 minutes
before she went out to save wubbo
because she took her dosimeter off first
they have no evidence
that this didn't happen and she's doing
all this because she doesn't want to be
grounded
we hear that in her conversation with
ellen where she tries to talk her out of
sending her home
while she does a pretty good job of
presenting her story of how things went
down
we can tell that she's been affected by
this she's not feeling good
as far as wubbo's concerned his
dosimeter registered 200 rems and that
means that he's gonna get cancer
as viewers we know that this means she
probably
will too considering how she looks the
effects they use on her scenes giving us
an idea of how this is affecting her
we know she's in trouble and it makes
sense that she would try to hide it
because there's nothing that she can do
about that at this point
her protests don't work ellen and molly
do go back to earth there's a fantastic
shot when they're leaving we see molly
floating there looking out the window
and we can imagine that she's thinking
that this is the last time she'll see
the moon on the surface she looks really
shaky she looks like she's sensitive to
the light and the sound
wayne's there to meet her and he sort of
takes her away from all the commotion
as far as the cast is concerned ellen
and molly
are our veterans of going to the moon we
heard ellen say that she's done four
tours and spent over 700 days at
jamestown
base and while ellen seems to be content
with that ready to move on to do
something else
molly definitely doesn't we saw last
episode that ellen was still married to
larry
all things considered their sham
marriage seems to be holding up
we see them at home here he has a
boyfriend staying the night they have a
whole routine
ellen isn't surprised by this still no
sign of pam or any word of what happened
to her
but we do see her transition to her new
position she's on the administration
side of things
and we hear larry tell her that the way
to mars is through washington not
through being an astronaut on the moon
basically
in a meeting with margot in the pentagon
we see her standing up for the mars
program she says they're five years in
and already 10 years behind we get the
idea that as far as nasa is concerned
and as far as the pentagon is concerned
mars is not their top priority
we don't spend too much time at jsc in
this episode but we do get filled out on
some details
beyond just seeing margot's
problem-solving skills when she defeats
the vending machine
in a serious battle we hear that the
threat level is back to defcon 5.
during the solar storm it was elevated
to defcon 3.
that meant there were planes in the air
everyone was at a high level of
readiness
and now the pentagon has eased that off
but they're still concerned
we learned that gary hart is a
presidential candidate which is
interesting because reagan is at the end
of his second term
the solar storm caused problems for the
reactor at jamestown base
so they're gonna have to refuel that and
we see generally that margot's stressed
in her position
there's that comment you'll figure it
out that's what you do and i think on
some level we're supposed to notice that
here
and another thing that really stands out
in margo's story this episode was the
reaction she had to the message
regarding elita
she goes out and asks her assistant and
when asked she just says
she's someone i knew from a long time
ago we don't really know what happened
there
there must have been a reason that we
spent so much time on elita in season
one
that had to be a setup for a bigger role
in season two
but we don't know what happened in the
meantime or why she's getting this
message now
she's definitely thrown off by it though
it's noticeable
and it'll be interesting to learn what
that's all about
so to bring back things to molly we see
her and wayne golfing with
ed and karen and ed knows better than to
believe her story
he says he's known her for a long time
and he says he knows there's no way that
she told the truth about waiting in the
lava tube
at this point he's just checking on her
there seems to be a level of
kinship of respect to the point where
he's not going to go tell anybody what
he knows
but he is checking and he does want her
to know that he knows that she
would have went out there in the
radiation it'll be interesting to see
how she reckons with that we see her
projecting things on wubbo later when
she blows up
he leaves the program himself because he
feels like he only has a few more years
to live
and he doesn't want to spend them there
as a part of this program
he probably wants to go home and spend
time with his family people he cares
about
molly is completely opposed to this but
it's obviously more about her than it is
about him
considering the secret that she's
keeping means that one way or the other
her ticket's punched too and on top of
that she's probably gonna die from
cancer
and you can imagine what that would be
like sitting in the back of your head
so on her end we see someone who's
trying to hold on
and then on gordo's end we see someone
who's trying not to go back
we see him at the outpost he's trying to
beat ed's high score on asteroids and
he's not able to do it
danny shows up she's having trouble
getting out of her car
we find out that they're all getting
together they do it regularly
and that she has something serious going
on clayton her husband
never recovered after the war after
being in vietnam
we met him in the first season
apparently he's committed suicide
and now she's decided that she wants to
go back to the moon
it's been nine years and ed tells her
that he'll set it up
we get some family time with gordo he's
still getting used to the idea tracy's
getting remarried but we see he's pretty
excited about his son
coming back from the naval academy and
seems pretty satisfied in that situation
even when tracy comes over they all get
along pretty well
later whenever they leave he gets super
drunk he ends up at the outpost he's a
complete mess
and karen has to call ed to come over
and get him as they go for a walk
ed puts it together how messed up gordo
is from their last experience on the
moon
he watches gordo break down he
eventually takes him home and puts him
to bed
and we see that he gets the idea that
he's gonna send gordo
back and he announces that the next day
in their meeting
gordo is immediately against the idea he
doesn't want to do it and we can see
that his friend is going to make sure
that
happens and i'm glad they got this out
of the way because we all saw the
trailer we all knew that gordo was gonna
probably do this
him and danny were both probably gonna
go back to the moon so it's nice that
that's underway now that he can
rehabilitate himself somewhat get ready
to go
and hopefully slay the dragon while he's
there right
confront his demons learn what he needs
to learn so that he can actually move on
from it
without a doubt my favorite scene in the
entire episode is the closing shot
we had this long shot of molly sitting
on the little wall
gordo walks up and asked to bum a
cigarette without saying anything she
just pulls one out
lights it for him hands it off he sits
down and it's just perfect and this is
really the moment i realized that all
that character work that they did in
season one is finally paying off
i like these guys flaws and all they're
all right with me
so we don't get a lot of karen in this
episode or really much ed on his own
either but we do get some scenes with
their daughter their adopted daughter
who we know nothing about
she's just sort of there right now at
this point this is probably what i was
least interested in in this episode
this and the stephen's kids as well i
imagine that this is also setting up
something in the future
similar to what i was talking about with
the elita stuff in season one
it just feels a little out of place at
this point
and we do get a little bit of tracy we
see that she's doing a modeling gig
she's wearing her suit she's probably
getting paid pretty good money for this
padding out that government paycheck she
seems happy
we know she got married we see the ring
again
things seem to be going pretty good in
that part of her life she seems to be
ducking her
responsibilities a little bit in her
astronaut training
that may come up later but there is
tension between her and
ed in relation to her not telling gordo
about getting married
before she announced it on tv so it's a
little hard to see
where they're going with tracy at this
point she does have a cell phone that
was kind of fun to see
maybe those are more accessible more
common in the 1983 alternate timeline
and that's really all there is i can say
about what happened given that it is a
setup episode
they needed to get gordo and danny back
in training
and get ready to send them back to the
moon it's interesting that gordo
is clearly not happy doing what he's
doing we see him talking to some
shriners here
he looks like he's put on about 40
pounds he's drinking heavily
but what's interesting is he prefers
that over the idea of going back to the
moon he's terrified of that
from what we can gather danny seems a
lot more gung-ho
as far as the events in her private life
it looks like this is something that
really means something to her
and we can't forget about the fact that
she made a real sacrifice for gordo the
last time they were there
so i like the setup some other things
that i wanted to mention
man there are so many people on
jamestown base this thing is fully
staffed at this point
it's something to see really and i liked
watching ellen say goodbye to it
she helped build it she's been there
she's put in time there
it's a part of who she is and i thought
you could feel that when she was getting
ready to leave
she's telling herself i have this other
stuff to do on earth i think i can be of
more use there but you can see that she
has real feelings about the base
about leaving the moon behind and we can
imagine that applies to everybody
i also like that she's the advocate for
the mars missions i think we're gonna
see movement there
i think it's inevitable that there will
be a mars program
maybe not this season but it is
something that will have to happen
and it's good to know that she'll be
involved with that we heard other
mentions of the pathfinder shuttle there
was talk of putting missiles on board
which is on hold for now according to
payne
but i feel like there's some big reveals
coming in that part of the story we're
gonna see them continue to progress
new technology new missions see how the
space program
develops under these different
circumstances
and i'm excited to see it i think that's
a good place to leave things
we could pick up the discussion in the
comments let me know what you're
thinking
where do you think we're going from here
what did you like the best about this
episode what are you hoping to see in
the next
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon